Nineteen hundred and twenty- dix-neuf-cent-trente-quatre.
Well, it happens,
it happened in Vienna,
I don't know if you know it comes.
.. The time,
it was the social democracy that had the mayor's office of Vienna,
uh well,
the social democracy,
it's the PS, eh...
Well,
at the time when the PS was on the left and at the
time when the PS was socialist even.
..
So it's sure that it's not quite the same politicians in the result,
but uh...
There was 1 policy very voluntary housing,
including with rent blocks,
with uh Construction companies that were public were municipal and uh Today
come for example 1 century later,
it remains 1 city with more than 60% social housing So to say the traces that
it leaves more than a century later.